[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa más
romero sala ya está conmigo en el
estudio mar muy buen día bienvenida
feliz y ernest para ti como estado la
llegada de los talibanes al sistema de
salud de los afganos e en torno a
nuestro tema del día que ha sido no los
memes desde la llegada de los talibanes
al poder en ese país claros ha tenido
muchísimas consecuencias también sobre
la salud de todas las personas que viven
en ese país empecemos por decir que los
sistemas de salud están totalmente
desbordados ya veníamos de un sistema de
salud que era frágil no por poner un
ejemplo la esperanza de vida en
afganistán ronda los 63 años que es una
mejora importante en las últimas décadas
pero sigue siendo muy baja entonces ya
viniendo de un lugar precario ahora es
todavía peor sobre todo por la falta de
financiación en el sistema sanitario
afgano es uno de los más dependientes de
la ayuda internacional de la ayuda
humanitaria entonces pues eso está
haciendo que no se pueda atender como se
debería a muchísimas de las personas que
lo necesitan además también está
habiendo una especie de de avalancha de
personas que llegan a los hospitales por
un lado porque eran personas que estaban
enfermas que durante las semanas y meses
de un conflicto más crudo no podían
llegar a esos hospitales y por otro lado
porque muchas personas también que han
quedado heridas del conflicto o de los
atentados que como hoy estamos viendo
que siguen ocurriendo en afganistán
repasemos las cifras de los del sistema
de salud hospitalario en afganistán si
te parece
hay dos tercios de los hospitales que
ahora mismo no están pudiendo tener
medicamentos esenciales eso es muy
importante para poder atender a los
pacientes y no lo están pudiendo hacer
solo un 20 por ciento de los hospitales
públicos ahora mismo están en
funcionamiento los que quedan en pie
principalmente son de organizaciones
internacionales y hay 20.000
trabajadores de la salud de los cuales
7.000 son mujeres que dejaron de
trabajar o lo están haciendo sin cobrar
un sueldo además una última cifra a la
cruz de la cruz roja' precisamente hay
2.000 centros sanitarios que han cerrado
desde la llegada de los talibanes al
poder escuchemos los testimonios que
llegan desde ahí
llevamos tres meses sin sueldo
y todos necesitamos los doctores las
enfermeras los trabajadores esenciales
el software
tenemos capacidad de 155 camas
y el número de pacientes que tuvimos
esta mañana era de 226 casi el doble
además de esto mar está la pandemia de
kobe 19 que seguramente no debe mejorar
esta situación ya pues no de hecho
empezamos siendo realistas el coach 19
probablemente es la última preocupación
de muchísimos afganos en este momento
pero eso no quiere decir que la
enfermedad no siga presente y de hecho
es una enfermedad que está in atendida y
nueve hospitales que trataban
específicamente el kobe 19 que ya no
están funcionando además poco más de un
2% de la población está vacunada con una
de las dosis del fármaco contra el cob y
19 y eso teniendo 18 millones de dosis
de vacunas que están sin usar y que
corren el riesgo de caducar se de aquí a
fin de año porque ahora mismo pues la
distribución está prácticamente
los doctores desde kabul alertan de los
riesgos
la tasa de mortalidad de kobe 19 crecerá
en afganistán
de manera diaria veremos muertes en
nuestras comunidades
[Música]
sin financiación no podemos dar un buen
tratamiento a los pacientes de kobe 19
encuentran prisión
aunque aniston ahora según las cifras
oficiales tiene algo más de 7.200
muertes por kobe 19 es una cifra muy
baja pero claro es muy difícil saber si
en verdad se ajusta a la realidad además
tenemos que recordar también que en un
pasado cuando los talibanes estuvieron
en el poder se opusieron a la vacunación
contra la polio una de las enfermedades
endémicas en el país por lo tanto no
está claro qué pasará ahora sí sí
respaldarán las campañas de vacunación
contra el cob en 19 o por el contrario
como han hecho en el pasado las
obstaculizarán vamos a ver qué va a
pasar y si quiere serlo pregunten a esta
segunda mitad del día sobre este tema
mar pero ahora le pregunto qué pasa con
las mujeres que trabajan en el ámbito
sanitario pues de hecho como has visto
el último testimonio que hemos recogido
que además por cierto llegó a nosotros
gracias a la agencia afp ha hecho un
gran trabajo en el terreno era una mujer
era una mujer doctor hablando de kobe 19
porque estaba trabajando en un hospital
internacional se sabe que hay doctoras
enfermeras profesionales de la salud que
están pudiendo trabajar en esos lugares
por un lado también porque pues la
emergencia sanitaria lo requiere y los
talibanes están teniendo que ser
flexibles sobre todo en áreas remotas en
áreas rurales del país porque si no los
hospitales no podrían seguir funcionando
de hecho de uno de estos hospitales de
un área rural de afganistán llega un
testimonio también de una chica que
explica pues por qué sigue trabajando
escuchamos lo
quiero mantener mi lucha nunca diré que
ha sido suficiente que no seguiré
trabajando que hay demasiadas
dificultades
no importa cuantas dificultades hayan
seguiré haciendo mi trabajo mientras
tenga la oportunidad
continuaré con mi deber sin importar la
situación
pero claro hay dos lados de la historia
no las mujeres como trabajadores de la
salud y luego también las mujeres como
pacientes la salud de las mujeres bajo
gobierno talibán está completamente en
riesgo sobre todo por ejemplo uno de los
ejemplos es en los temas de maternidad
de los nacimientos afganistán que una de
las tasas de mortalidad materna más
altas del mundo son
638 muertes maternas por cada 100.000
nacimientos es un ejemplo de como
también de precaria estaba ya la
atención sanitaria para las mujeres y
cómo puede empeorar de hecho recordemos
que ahora mismo en principio según el
leyes talibanes las mujeres no pueden
desplazarse libremente sin el
acompañamiento de un hombre considerado
responsable y eso va a dificultar
enormemente que estas mujeres puedan
atender su salud de manera autónoma por
ejemplo de manera propia eso pone muy en
riesgo todo el progreso que se había
logrado en los últimos 20 años y que
ahora podemos ver como quizás empeorará
pues lamentable marc pues ojalá no
empeore en que todo apunta a que va para
allá no necesitaremos
más muchísimas gracias nos vemos el
lunes con más salud aquí en directo
américa vamos a